we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p today's
voicemail is really really short and
sweet let's take a listen they did a lot
that could mean any number of things but
clearly somebody uh and you might have
been able to tell from their accent we
could tell from the caller ID they are
from the south of the United States
clearly somebody that does not
appreciate the hard work Pat that goes
into this program does he it makes me
wonder what's going on with his life to
it all yesterday was call into the show
what are you doing day to day buddy
that's so great that you uh call me and
tell me to get a life I'd like to know
that on today's bonus show we will talk
about an airline introducing child free
zones this is very very interesting i
think i like some element of this we
will talk about generation adderall i
know there are people in our audience
who are going to find that story
interesting and i will give you an
update on the david pakman show 2017
calendar all of those stories and more
on the bonus show but there's only one
way to get access to that bonus show you
might have heard me mention this before
it's david pakman.com slash membership
and you can use if you want to get a
discount off of your membership you can
use coupon code hey tree at 40 that's
h80 are iot 40 40 percent discount off
of your membership with the coupon code
sign up we'll talk to you on the bonus
show